the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
if it's coming from places we don't
understand that's still okay
tonight on politics now uncovering the
truth behind ufos
former senator harry reid talks about
senate investigations and new videos
coming out now
and i am fully aware of the popularity
of mentioning well any tax source
frankly paying for education
recommendations from the nevada
commission on school
funding to get children the education
they need
we have a real chance to root out
systemic racism
and lawmakers react to president biden's
first speech to congress
how republicans are reacting to his
message of bipartisanship
from eight news now this is politics now
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langlow we are now officially at
80 percent capacity and three feet
social distancing in las vegas
as we battle the pandemic counties
officially took over control of
mitigation efforts today
this week governor steve sisilak
encouraged everyone to get their
vaccination
i'm committed to making las vegas and
nevada the safest
place to vacation and to have a
convention that's only going to be done
through what you're seeing behind me is
needles in people's arms
in order for nevada and clark county to
get 100 percent open clark county and
the state wants 60 percent of adults to
be vaccinated by june 1st
right now we're at about 25 percent full
vaccination
this week president joe biden gave his
first address to a joint session of
congress
he gave his vision for the country while
pushing some major spending packages
rashad hudson has reaction from
lawmakers on capitol hill
this is so exciting democrats like house
speaker nancy pelosi say
they're ready to begin working on the
ambitious agenda president biden laid
out in wednesday's address
to congress as the president said last
night
america is moving in the speech
president biden called for passing his
infrastructure plan
immigration and police reform as well as
voting rights and gun safety
we have a real chance to root out
systemic racism
that plagues america and american lives
in other ways
the president however did not win over
republicans like senate minority leader
mitch mcconnell and the president talked
about unity and togetherness while
reading off a multi-trillion dollar
shopping list
that was neither designed nor intended
to earn bipartisan buy-in alabama
senator tommy tuberville says
president biden's plans are too
expensive and radical
we gave way a lot of money in a short
period of time my calculator
about burned up i was trying to count
but senate majority leader chuck schumer
says
the president's agenda is working under
president biden
and democratic majorities in congress
america is
turning the corner 6.4 percent growth
wow the president is now taking his
message on the road with trips to
georgia
and pennsylvania in washington i'm
rashad hudson
southern nevada's congressional
delegation are all democrats
they sent out press releases after the
speech praising president biden's
performance
in carson city the legislative session
is rolling on state senate majority
leader nicole canezzaro is now pushing a
public
option for health insurance she
introduced senate bill 420 this week
health insurers would have to offer a
cheaper public option as a condition of
being on the state health exchange
the bill also increases medicaid for
pregnant nevadans
it was sent to the health and human
services committee and given an
exemption
a first hearing has not been scheduled
yet opposition
quickly sprung up a group of doctors
hospitals and pharmaceutical companies
calling itself
nevada healthcare future nevada's
healthcare future
they have spent millions of dollars
opposing similar public option bills in
other states
in other legislative news governor steve
sisilak is giving up on the idea for a
blockchain
company controlled independent city in
nevada northern nevada
it would have created autonomous
innovation zones similar to county
governments but not part of them
the first project was slated for 67 000
acres up in story county owned by
blockchains llc company but the
legislation never got finished
the governor says he now wants to create
a study to look into the idea more
deeply
fully funding nevada's schools is still
very much on the agenda up in carson
city
the commission on school funding put out
its report with recommendations last
week
the commission says nevada's per pupil
funding is around 9 200
you see the numbers here on your screen
the national average
is more than twelve thousand dollars
it's more to fully fund this new plan
nevada would have to get to more than
fourteen
thousand dollars per student the
commission says it would take
two billion extra dollars over the next
10 years to properly fund the new nevada
education formula
that's 55 percent more than our current
funding
they suggested paying for it by raising
sales and property taxes
governor siselek says he is looking at
the recommendations from that report but
we wanted to hear straight from the
commission itself
the i-team's vanessa murphy spoke with
one of the commission's vice chairs
economist guy hobbs and they started
with hobbs explaining that two billion
dollar figure
if you take that difference between
ninety two hundred and say twelve
thousand
uh six hundred and you inflate it
forward
by ten years you know what will that
what will the value of those dollars be
in ten years
that comes out to about 2.2 billion more
in
spending than what is being spent today
per year now i
my reaction to that number is that's a
rather large number
um unquestionably so and so over that
10-year period roughly you'd have to
average 220 million
each year in new funding
so you have to ask yourself what sorts
of revenue
options do you have out there that are
even capable
of producing that amount of revenue and
that immediately eliminates a lot of
other you know sources or or
charges or fees or those kinds of things
because they just don't have the
capability of producing that kind of
revenue
and and i i think another point is
since you're talking about education
funding and since we placed such a
premium on that
you want something that's stable and
predictable over time now
sales tax hasn't proven to be as stable
over the years it tends to dip with
recessions property tax
is relatively stable so to meet those
two conditions
the amount of money involved and have it
be
relatively stable from year to year you
don't have many
other choices and i am fully aware of
the popularity
of um mentioning well any tax source
frankly viewers may see this and say
how could this be in a state
with an international a tourism
destination and how could this be
with the marijuana attacks that we heard
about
for you know quite a while so can you
talk about
how they fit in here
yeah and i think the other thing that
you know in the how could this be in the
state that
people have to remember too is that how
could it be that this state has all of
the needs that it has and doesn't have
certain tax sources that are even less
popular
than the ones that we mentioned earlier
in property and sales tax like it's a
state without an income
tax you have gaming the hospitality
industry you have mining
both of those could certainly be looked
to you could put together
a bundle of different funding sources it
doesn't have to be exclusively the
property tax or exclusively
the sales tax it could be a blending of
a lot of different types of revenue
sources
but one of the reasons that the
commission leaned toward property tax as
well is that cuts across
all spectrums of business it includes
residents and businesses alike
it's broader based than picking a single
industry tax source and the one other
thing that i would always remind people
about
with respect to single industry tax
sources is they become economically
volatile
what about the marijuana money though
because we hear about that a lot from
viewers
does it generate an average of 220
million dollars a year
no it does not at this point um
a portion of that is already dedicated
to education
but just the same as a portion of room
tax is dedicated to education
what are the consequences if a
drastic change isn't made if taxes
aren't raised
property or sales tax what is the
consequence of just
leaving things as is we
collectively i guess are accepting the
fact that what we're doing is okay
and that we don't need to make any
changes and if that's if that's the
prevailing viewpoint
then i guess you could say that what
we're spending today is adequate and
what we're getting out of it
is what we think we should be getting
out of it now i don't hear too many
people say that
now the commission was created by senate
bill 543 in the 2019 session
that creates the new nevada funding plan
where the money follows the student
we've covered that a lot certainly
but it did not come with a way to pay
for that program
lawmakers find out what the budget will
be at the economic forum on tuesday the
legislative council bureau expects to
have 80 million dollars
more than originally thought now that as
you see on your screen there
that is on top of this year's budget
having an extra 74 and a half million
dollars
all together that is 155 million dollars
more than the december economic forum
projected
most of that extra money comes from one
place net proceeds from mining taxes
the nevada assembly has approved a plan
to remove unused decorative grass
ab356 is being pushed by the southern
nevada water authority
if it passes the senate no water from
the colorado river could be used for
ornamental grass on businesses or public
thoroughfares
starting in 2027. now this is specific
to decorative grass like on traffic
medians
roundabouts places where people don't
walk not your backyards for example
right now the bureau of water
reclamation expects lake mead
incidentally to hit its lowest point
ever in a few months and then
unfortunately keep going down from there
coming up here on politics now learning
about ufos
we can't ignore the subject even if he
wanted to
up next former senator harry reid's
advice to the president
about the phenomenon and his push for
more investigation
welcome back to politics now well more
videos are coming out from the
pentagon's investigation into
unidentified flying objects recently the
pentagon confirmed three pictures taken
by navy pilots off the virginia coast
are from just two years ago and now
members of a task force are briefing
congress on exactly what they've found
mystery wires george knapp has broken
many of these stories for a long long
time
he spoke with former nevada senator
harry reid about ufo investigations in
congress
do you uh anticipate him getting a
briefing on the
ufo uap topic at some point or is it too
early in his presidency
i think it's a little early but i have
no problem
talking to a shetty or claim and telling
them that he should get a briefing
because
i don't want him to be embarrassed at a
press conference or something
and he said no i don't know anything
about that i think he should at least
have the ability to say i've
been briefed on the subject and i have
no opinion or whatever he want to say
but yes i think that that the
topic of ufos is not going away
it's becoming more pronounced for a lot
of different reasons so he can't
ignore the subject even if he wanted to
i learned that you have written
sort of an op-ed piece for the new york
times i i don't know if we are
can talk about it now or when it's going
to be out but what did you want to say
what do you want to say in the new york
times well i've said it already uh
they have it it's up to them when
they're gonna when they're gonna run it
basically what i've done is indicated
that uh
i've been involved in this i told them
how i got involved in it
and that uh it's something that
can't be ignored and i'm happy that
we're making progress
the federal government no longer uh
including people at the pentagon no
longer
uh criticize or harass
or stop promotions of people who report
these occurrences
in fact they have done just the opposite
in recent months
they now tell their pilots those that
they
see to report these unusual
circumstances and
i appreciated the honesty of the
pentagon
because when asked what were these
things they say
we don't know rather than try to say
they were balloons from
uh some kind of a weather experiment
they said
we don't know and that's honest
that's being honest let's say the uh
science comes up with pieces of material
that's not from here
or a craft or a being or
something irrefutable that demonstrates
that this is somebody else it's from
somewhere else
how do you think the american public
will react can we handle it
i don't know how the public will end but
i think
as long as we understand that
we need to make sure that we are
scientifically driven
that uh we're gonna be okay and if it's
coming from
places we don't understand that's still
okay as long as we understand
that there is stuff coming from other
places the uap task force
uh is going to give its report to
congress and maybe do a follow-up report
but that a lot of people think that's
not enough do you
feel that there should be support for a
more permanent
study of this some kind of an
organization like what you started a
long time ago
that has an ongoing responsibility for
figuring this out
yes the federal government spends
trillions of dollars every year
and i believe that there should be an
ongoing uh
entity within the pentagon would be the
best place for it
whose sole job is to stay on top of the
issue of
ufos we have a lot more of that
interview and the most recent ufo
videos on mysterywire.com
cpac and the american conservative union
gave the lone republican and nevada
delegation a semi-passing grade giving
congressman mark amide a 68 percent
great as you see on your screen there
the rest of our delegation are all
democrats and they range from
zero percent for congresswoman dina
titus is coming from the conservatives
of course
uh cpac said that she was uh something
that she was proud of a bigger party
miss titus said she was proud of that
a nine for our other senators catherine
cortez masto and jackie rosen
a man called the most dangerous inmate
in nevada died last week while sitting
on death row
patrick mckenna was 74 years old mckenna
was sentenced
to death for killing his cellmate in
1979
also was convicted for kidnapping sexual
assault and robbery
mckenna also sparked a days-long siege
in 1979 at the old city
jail his surrender was eventually
negotiated by
former channel 8 news director bob
stoddall and during a prison interview
george knapp asked mckenna about his
notorious reputation
it's a mixture of of this
personal this persona that's been
created by
some of the things i've done and some of
the things that d.a has
fabricated the prosecutors over the
years
and uh it's a combination of all that
a little truth a little not so true
you can watch those stories on eight
newsnow dot com
next on politics now the fast lane to
phoenix we asked the transportation
secretary
how the american rescue plan could
improve our highways and possibly finish
i-11
you're watching politics now
this week nevada democratic senator
catherine cortez masto held a virtual
round table
about ending violence against indigenous
women specifically
missing and murdered girls i am going to
keep
doing everything i can to make sure our
tribes in nevada and across the country
get the full support of the federal
government
and to today's conversation is just one
part of making sure
our native uh women and girls get every
protection that we can offer cortez
masto worked to pass the not invisible
act it increases communication between
the government and tribal nations to
fight these type of crimes
while the country and capitol hill are
talking about infrastructure one
question is
what does that mean for nevada well we
spoke with transportation secretary pete
budajudge about
widening i-15 and finishing i-11 to
phoenix
that's the thing when you have a
fast-growing and dynamic area like
southern nevada it's more important than
ever to make sure we're making the right
infrastructure investments to stay
competitive it's not the kind of place
that can just coast along on things that
were put in at one or two generations
ago
and so i've heard from her and other
members of the delegation
about just how important it is to make
sure that we're invested now
that means having resources that means
having an initiative like this
and that's why from the just making sure
we have an adequate baseline of funding
to creating the funds for what we're
calling projects of regional
significance like some of
what you're describing we think it's so
important because when you get it right
it'll actually unlock future growth and
create a stronger economy for
years and years we have much more of
that interview
on eight newsnow dot com the u.s has
seen near record levels of unaccompanied
children arriving at the southern border
in recent months
however immigration experts told
congress recently we may be turning a
corner
alexandra limon tells us how the
situation is starting to improve
california congresswoman nanette baragan
says there's a reason
migrant children are coming to the u.s
northern triangle countries suffer
from unspeakable violence corruption
and poverty vice president kamala harris
is leading the u.s effort to improve the
situation at the southern border
one change is children can now apply for
asylum from their home countries
the suspension of wall system
construction was
a major a major error louisiana
republican congressman clay higgins says
the biden administration's policies are
making the problem
worse these circumstances have invited
this activity to our border
but erin reichlen melnick from the
american immigration council says the
situation at the border
is starting to improve the number of
children in border patrol custody has
dropped
80 percent since late march and as of
this morning the average time in border
patrol custody for unaccompanied
children is below 48 hours
by law children must be transferred out
of cbp custody within 72 hours
and the biden administration is now able
to meet that requirement because of the
network of emergency shelters
it opened around the country but
advocates warned those shelters are not
permanent solutions thankfully here as
well the bind administration's efforts
have begun to pay off
last thursday for the first time since
reporting began
more children left u.s custody than
entered it in washington
alexandra limon
in what to watch this week we're
certainly keeping an eye on nevada
opening back up
with kovid mitigation control being
turned over to counties
we're watching to see if vaccination
rates can continue to decline
the target is 60 percent vaccination of
the population in order to
fully reopen the state on june 1st so
we'll watch that
next tuesday is also the economic forum
up at the state legislative session
they'll know exactly how much lawmakers
have to spend on the state budget
at this point we're expected to have
extra money but sometimes there are some
surprises we'll keep an eye on what
happens
up in carson city and we thank you very
much for watching politics now don't
forget
for the latest political news happening
in nevada and across the country
watch us here and of course head on to
eight newsnow dot com we'll see you next
week have a good rest of the day
[Music]
you